Okay, we are ready. This is a big per-second video, a genetics training. And here with my guests,
I push down and Ashley. So, all right. So, last time we left off talking about the
oxalite genes. We didn't talk about the ket genes because I just don't know enough about them yet.
And so, there's more that we got to keep steady about these ones that Bob is throwing
into the program because one of his researchers found, hey, this is really cool, but we need
to learn more about them. Okay, I know the HR-H genes, these have to do with histamine,
desingine. So, there's genes, we talk about histamine, there's genes that make an enzyme that
break down histamine, but then you got to go, you could spend months just studying about each one
of these chemicals that our body makes and what they do in our body. So, that's where we don't
want to villainize something like histamine because it does all sorts of fantastic things in our body,
but it's just like anything else in abundance, it could cause problems. And the reason why we have
so many histamine issues in our society is because really we're exposed to so many things that
damage our gut that we talked about, that it's causing this constant, ramped up chronic inflammatory
response in our body. So, we could say that that's a big part of all diseases is this chronic inflammation,
it's just this chronic state of inflammation that we have. And then you go, what is that front
was from all the toxic exposure that we have, our damage gut. So, even good things, foods are causing
inflammation in our body, and it's just getting out of hand. So, these HRH genes we need to learn a lot
more about with studying these and I don't know what they do and how they function in our body.
These IL-13 ones, these dark ones, I don't know what these do yet. So, I'm still learning them. I know
this FCER has to do with the immune response and the IgE response. And these IL-13, that stands for
interleukin-13. There's a whole bunch of, you asked the question about chemokines. Well, there's
chemical messengers in our body called chemokines. And other group of chemical messengers call
cytokines. Cytokines are the interleukins and they are immune communicators, you can say.
So, different interleukins turn on different immune type systems. Matter of fact, one of the chemotherapy
drugs that keep true to what part of what that's doing is to stimulate IL-2 interleukin-2, which is
then stimulates your T cell function. Interleukin-13 stimulates the TH-2 side of the immune system,
where IL-2 stimulates the TH-1 side of the immune system. But there's a whole bunch of different
interleukins that have to do with different immune type stimulants. And this is just a new gene that
they pulled out that was always tested and we're still learning on what that does and defects in
that what that could be related to. The rad-50 genes are also immune stimulant genes, but these have
been linked to cervical cancer, colorectal cancers, and I think breast cancer, these rad-50 genes. So,
there's going to be a lot to look at. Well, we hopefully do that on the genetic study with all
our cancer patients going into the system and see what percentage of them have rad-50 defects or
histamine defects. So, you know, we're going to see a correlation. So, that will be interesting
to figure that out. And then separating the set of the FUT2 genes, separating out some of the other
FUT2 genes and what they do, they're just don't know yet. Okay? So, then you get into the energy
genes, the crem cycle genes, the genes that, so let's see, do I have a chart on crem cycle and what
that is so you guys know what we're talking about. So, I don't remember if I have a chart here with
the crem cycle, I don't think I have it in here. So, you could pull up glycolysis crem cycle,
the internet, go to some images to see what it is. And let's see a good picture. Oh boy, that's
not very big. So, in the crem cycle itself, so the crem cycle, there's a better picture of it,
but that's really small too. Probably there's a lot of things going on in the crem cycle.
Crem cycle is also called the citric acid cycle, that's a little bit better picture right there.
So, starting right here with pyruvate, pyruvate is the end product of glycolysis. So, remember,
that pathway a little bit. So, your sugar intake, this picture right here. So, carbohydrates
break down to glucose, right? And glucose goes through what's missing right here is glycolysis.
And glycolysis is the purpose is to break down glucose to pyruvate. And in that cycle of glycolysis,
it gives off some energy. So, the whole purpose in glucose utilization in your body is to make
energy. It's just to make energy. So, could you live without glucose? Yes, but how are you going to
get your energy? So, then your body will use a totally different pathway. That's the ketogenic
pathway. So, what ketosis is, is that you're burning ketones for energy instead of glucose. So,
in order to get into ketosis, that's a ketogenic diet, that's so hip right now. You have to deprive
yourself of all sources of carbohydrates to get into ketosis. So, really, in order to get into
ketosis, or there's a lot of people on a ketogenic that say, oh, I'm a ketogenic, and I've been
a ketone, burning ketones. Well, I doubt that. In truth, you really have to go on a three to five
day water fast, only water to get to a state where you're where you're really in ketosis.
And the way you could measure whether you're in ketosis is by measuring blood ketone levels.
So, someone who's truly, truly ketogenic has a blood glucose running about 60, which would be
technically hypoglycemic for anybody else, but they've got their body to an efficient state where
they're burning ketones instead of glucose. Is that always necessary? Absolutely not. Is it always
even healthy? Absolutely not. We were meant to burn glucose. So, to say, oh, everybody should be
in a ketogenic diet, that's ridiculous. However, if you really define it the way they're really
going to find it, which is wrong, most people are on a ketogenic diet are not really in ketosis.
They're just really, really limiting their carbohydrates, which would that be good for everybody? Sure.
And getting their glucose levels down would that be good for everybody? Absolutely. They're really not
very ketones though, but they're really limiting this, what's going through glycolysis.
So, but they still have glucose points for glycolysis. glycolysis literally means
lysis of glucose, right? glycolysis. So, it's breaking down glucose in order to make pyruvate and
then pyruvate goes into the crev cycle. So, this is really the crev cycle right here or the citric
acid cycle. So, pyruvate breaks down through that time limited step of using the pdh gene.
So, the pdh gene makes it enzyme that breaks down pyruvate. It's pyruvate deoxidase whatever,
right? So, that breaks down pyruvate to this very important moment you'll call acetylcoil inside A.
Also, there's another gene that limits this step strongly and that's the HIF1A gene. So,
defects in the pdh gene, defects in the HIF gene are really, really important when you talk about
a cancer patient, especially a cancer patient's diet. Because if they have defects in that then
pyruvate does not get broken down due acetylcoins, they may very well. And this is what auto-warberg
discovered years ago that when the six, I noticed that a lot of cancer patients, their cancers have
such high concentrations of lactic acid. The cancers are feeding off of lactic. Wasn't all cancer
patients though. It's just a percentage of them. So, why would cancer feed off of lactic acid?
Because this only produces so much energy, not even a tenth of what it would produce if the cells,
think of the cancer. This is what's taking place in a cell, right? So, if the cancer cell
they have high concentrations of this and this is what the cancer speed off of and hardly anything's
going through the cramps cycle. What he hypothesized was that cancer cells, because this takes place
in the mitochondria. This takes place in the cytoplasm of the cell. That means, so go through the cell bed
bright, think of the cell bed bright as a wall or around the cell, three eventually. And the cytoplasm
is the jelly that makes up the cell inside of the cell. And inside that jelly, I say it's a jelly
because it's not just air, it's not just space, it's liquid. Inside that, it's space is tons of
chemicals like the Betty is New York City. And all these different processes have to take place inside
the cell. Well, glycolysis takes place inside the cell. Sublycolysis is thought to take place in
the mitochondria. The mitochondria or the team where it is in the cell, so think of that as a giant
warehouse in New York City. And there's thousands of mitochondria in a cell, so there's thousands of
these warehouses that are whole purpose is to make energy. So they're not warehouses, they're actually
they're actually excel energy plants that they make energy and they do so through the citrus acid
cycle and the fatty acid cycle. So that's how you make energy. Well, you do make some sort of glycolysis,
so some is made of the cytoplasm. Yeah, that's true, but very little, we don't really count so
much in what made it through this. And we don't really count what's made very black to gas. It's so
little that it doesn't really count, but then it's like, well, how come cancer cells are using this?
And they need to reproduce so quickly and move so quickly is it because they're too impatient for this
step to get it to to grab cycle. Well, it doesn't make a whole lot of sense. And then the thought was
well, cancer, cancer cells have a damage by a hundred. Well, in a sense, that is really true,
but how do we define damage? I think it's because of this is just solely my theory. All right, so I'm
telling you guys this so you can carry on this theory and maybe prove it to be right or wrong. I think
patients that have a defect in this gene or in this gene are make it's much more time consuming
to convert pyruvate to acetylquids and they, and therefore, since cancer has to reproduce quickly,
it's going to get it through this way. Okay. Matter of fact, there are some cancers and right now
it's mainly the lymphomas that you can measure. So LDH is a gene and it makes LDH, which is lactate
dehydrogenase. So you can measure lactate dehydrogenase in a blood test. And they're finding that
some cancers have very high LDH levels. Matter of fact, there was a study out just recently, if you
let's go there, the study, well, this might be a new marker for cancer patients, high LDH levels.
Okay. Well, we could say this, that this is the way cancer, some cancers feed, right? Well,
course, this enzyme is going to be going nuts because this is going to be really working hard,
this is going to be kicky-dow hard because it's, it's pushing this pathway this way
in some cancer patients. Those are the patients that, how are you going to cut off this supply chain now?
How would you cut off this supply chain if we knew that the cancer was being fed this way?
Well, hypoxia stimulates this. So this is a stimulator? So hypoxia increases that activity.
So we want to stimulate this pathway, right? So oxygen would help, so give it a
person oxygen, so get it out and get it some exercise would help, right?
Get it out, go ahead and the oxygen chamber would help, right?
Would there be any benefit to do that hydrogen water you've been talking about?
That's hydrogen, that doesn't help to improve your body's ability to oxygenate cells through
maybe secondarily. No good nutrition helps oxygenate, so that's true too. But how about
so we're stimulating this pathway? What else, where do we, how would we cut it off? Should we
eliminate this as much as possible? So this is where it's coming from. If the person doesn't have glucose,
they can't feed this, right? It's impossible. So if you, this is the people that should go out of
the more ketogenic type diet. Is predominant if they have defects in the PDHG?
So that we test for, do they have lots of pyruvate? So with kinesiology, we test, do they have lots
of this? Then I say we should go on a ketogenic diet. So if they have a lot of this substrate
and this substrate, they need to go on a ketogenic diet. And if you did a blood test,
you could test for this. Do they have a lot of this? They need to go on a ketogenic diet. If they
have defects here and here, they need to go on a ketogenic diet. Does that make sense?
So those are the people that were putting it on a more keto-like diet and we don't put anybody
on a ketogenic diet because in reality, it's so difficult. And you've got to balance it out
with just kind of some reality. Full true ketogenic diet, person's going to lose weight.
Most are cancer patients who get it for the most weight. So the compromise, get them out of FFD.
Okay? Fasting Mimicking Diet. Get about a more keto diet. Really stress the low carb
aspect of this. Because technically, the fasting mimicking diet is almost
mimicking what the water fastest is. Like you were saying to help launch people into a ketogenic
state. That's right. And then if they maintain a ketogenic like diet, that's going to drop the glucose
levels down. Okay? Follow that. So I understand this pathway is the Krebs cycle. That's what that
looks like. And you can actually measure with the organic organics test. It's called an organic acid
test. The one from Genova diagnostics is called organics. But an organic acid test will measure
these substrates. It measures these different substrates in the Krebs cycle. So you could go even
deeper than with the patient. Not so much a cancer patient. But you could equate some things with
cancer. But other people have other issues is supporting issues in this pathway. One of the products
that we have out there on the shelf is called Betigene. That's Axalo Acetate right here.
So giving the cancer patient Axalo Acetate. You bypass this G right here. You bypass this.
And you're basically giving them a substrate that will instantly be in the Krebs cycle.
Follow me. So giving a person Axalo Acetate.
Can help that process too. The only issue that I have with Axalo Acetate is a really expensive
product. So it costs about $1.30 per capsule. And if you really want to use it the way I just said,
they have to be taking like 5 to 10 capsules a day. However, a person with with a brain cancer
this is where Axalo Acetate has there some studies on it. Especially astrocytomas that tend to
feed directly off of glutamate. If you could give a high dose of Axalo Acetate you could basically
shut off the glutamate shut. And there's really cool studies. One of my old mentors years ago his son
has a brain cancer and he basically put himself into a revision by taking a Axalo Acetate.
That's the bettige product. Now you can also use Axalo Acetate to reduce glutamates
in a person at a much lower level. But if you're really going to try to shut around
this whole piece then you have to do fairly high dose Axalo Acetate which is pricey.
Pricey, yet worth it if somebody is looking at legitimately trying to stop feeding it,
right? The cancer in that brain which is one of the most difficult types of cancers to detoxify
your body from. It is. And I think it would be worth it, you know, for a person who's
unstage cancer, we could get it to stop some other way. It's worth giving that a shock too.
It's just that way you're giving it a shock that's caused somebody to eat 20 bucks a day,
25 bucks a day in the product against glutamate. You know, so that you go what's the worth
the person's life, you know. Was that something we tested Sarah Kraft on at all?
I think it did. I don't remember. I can't remember. This was curious.
This was first primary brain tumor. No, it was the test. This was very diverse.
Okay, so I'm going to stop there because I have to leave it to call.